zwar ist luca und herzlich willkommen
hier heute meinen siemens zuschauer zu
einer neuen episode von
wir spielen ja heute immer wieder
movistar planet und zwar mal wieder mit
sinn die asic in der letzten folge haben
uns ja schon ein paar boys geklärt ich
werde mit dir picknicks bei
sonnenuntergang machen baby
und ich würde sagen der schule war heute
auch direkt weiter von daher gehe ich
jetzt mal wieder direkt in den chat
bereich reiner wild life keine ahnung
was das wieder für eine scheiße
kleiderordnung sich wieder fast 1000 ca
dann gehen wir halt nicht in den sport
live raum rein sondern gehen in das
einkaufszentrum das kommen da komme ich
da könnte da bin ich drin
meine damen und herren sind ea beim
shoppen wir sind auf jeden fall auch
noch einige andere leute mit am start
sie hat beispielsweise einfach den roten
teppich am start alles klar ich stelle
mich den ganzen leuten im
einkaufszentrum jetzt einfach mal
gewohnt freundlich folgen hier
übergewichtigen vollhorst ich bin
einfach wichtig dass man sympathisch
freundlich und kompetent bei den leuten
rüberkommt warum hat sie irgendwie
rückenschmerzen
mein gott bat gott lucadou alte schnitte
und veraltete ja nicht lukas oder ziel
wer ist loca loca loca du bist ein auto
das würde ich so geil ich will jetzt bin
ich auf einmal ein auto alter was bin
ich denn als nächstes an
also irgendwie ist das hier eine
komplette mädels ktm sie schreibt meine
puppe riechen besser als deine versuchst
du hier schön nach beuys im gegensatz zu
dir habe ich 1000 preis am start als
dritte schon jetzt kommt ihre weil am
start
heute.de was bin ich denn jetzt als
mittlerweile ist das einkaufszentrum auf
jeden fall übertrieben voll
alle fragen sich was sie irgendwie los
ist dieses mädel will mir meine boys the
clown seine boys sind hässlich
[Musik]
warum ist da plötzlich ein eis
du bist hässlich candy love 12
also ich weiß nicht wie er das werde
aber ich finds total frech ich komm nett
und freundlich in das einkaufszentrum
reingehen
sich gegen verluste und jetzt schreibt
diese candy love ihr schon wieder ich
bin schöner als sein rechter fuß
mein rechter fuß ist schöner als dein
ganzes leben hauptsache streiten man
sich in einem online game boys
lächerlich deal auftritt nicht passiert
leider von movistar blendet sehen sollte
schweißt die raue see ist so gemein
wir schauen uns einfach ihr profil an
also ich denke ich auf die candy auf 12
3 lauf haben sie ist level 10 ich bin
ich bin ist dafür hätte ich jetzt dein
haustier sieht schöner aus als du candy
love 123 mein haustier klärt keine boys
aber du oder wie ups wo bin ich gelandet
zickenkrieg also mir wird das ja auch
mittlerweile alles ein bisschen zu bunt
hat sich das ganz mit der canon i love
ihr alles ein bisschen hochgeschaukelt
von daher würde ich sagen ich
entschuldige mich jetzt mal freundlich
entschuldigung für mein verhalten kennen
die love 123 ich marken alter die tritte
und ich habe keine ahnung was das hier
soll
ich gehe jetzt mal einfach auf ihrem
trip ein und schreibe trittst schlechter
als ein tretboot dann hau ich gehe auf
deine fresse
[Musik]
ich habe keine ahnung ob das ist ja
alles ernst gemeint und franzi hier
schreibt also bei mir ist ja alles nur
ironischerweise so witzig alter diese
ganzen leute die diese spiele spielen
zum abschluss schreibe ich jetzt noch
mal allgemein dann alle leute in dem
raum gerichtet ihr alle hier seid
hässlich wie die nacht
mittel- und die richtige jaja anderer
stelle möchte heutige folge movistar
planet jetzt allerdings auch beende
meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat das unbedingt einen daumen
hoch hier unter dem video hier da und
schreibt ihn in die kommentare
jetzt und in die kommentare schreiben
was ich nächste woche machen sollen das
wird die letzte movistar planet folge
sein die ich hoch laden werde weiß
abonniert gern meinen kanal damit ihr
diese letzte folge nächsten samstag
nicht verpassen werde das ist kostenlos
und wenn ihr schon abonnent sind dann
klick gerne auf die glocke denn dann
bekommt er eine benachrichtigung sobald
sich ein neues video hochladen
kriege luftbilder
[Musik]
ein